hyeyeon you've been such a leader for
diva episode well thanks a lot for doing
this with us well thanks for so you've
been working on neural nets for a long
time um I'd love to hear your personal
story how did you get started a I have
your networking what neural networks so
I got interested in I was always
interested in the intelligence as in
general like the emergence of
intelligence in humans you know that
could be interested into you know human
evolution when I was a kid and there's
in France that was in France I was know
you know in the middle school or
something and you know I was interested
in technology and like you know space
etc you know my favorite movie was 2001
a Space Odyssey you know you had
intelligent machines you know space
travel and human evolution as kind of
the teams that was why I was fascinated
by and and you know the concept of
intelligent machine I think really kind
of appealed to me and then you know I
studied Electrical Engineering and when
I was a at school it was maybe in second
year of engineering school I stumbled on
the book which was actually philosophy
book it was a debate between Noam
Chomsky the computational linguist at
MIT and Jean Piaget who is a cognitive
psychologist psychologist of child
development in in Switzerland and it was
basically a debate between you know
nature and nurture where Chomsky arguing
for the fact that you know language is
as a lot of unit structure and pleasure
is saying you know a lot of it is
learned and etc and on the side of
Piaget was a transcription of a person
you know each of these guys that brought
their teams of people - I - you know
argue for their side and the side of
Piaget was Seymour Papert from MIT who
had worked on the perceptron model one
of the first machines capable of running
and I never heard of the perceptron and
I read this article it's a machine
capable of running that sounds wonderful
and so I I started going to several
university libraries and searching for
all you know everything I could find
that talked about the perceptron I
realized there was a lot of papers from
the fifties but the
it kind of stopped at the end of the
sixties with a book that was co-authored
by the same same Apep earn what year was
this that so this was in 1980 roughly
right and so I specialized I did a
couple projects with some of the math
professor in my school on kind of neural
nets essentially but there was no one I
could talk to who you know had worked on
this because the field basically had
disappeared in the mean time right it's
1980 nobody was working on this and you
know experimented with this a little bit
you know writing kind of simulation
software various kinds reading about
neuroscience when I finished my
engineering studies I studied chip
design you get a site design at the time
so something awfully different and when
I finished I really wanted to kind of do
research on this and I you know figured
out already that at the time that the
important question was how you train
neural nets with multiple layers it was
pretty clear the literature of the 60s
that that was the important question
that was that I didn't left unsolved and
the idea of hierarchy and everything you
know I'd read
Fukushima's article in the new cognate
all right which was the sort of
hierarchical architecture very similar
to now we now commercial Nets but you
know with without really without back
pop star learning algorithms and I met a
small I met people who were in a small
independent lab in France that they were
interested in what would they call at
the time automata networks and they gave
me a couple of papers the people on
hopeful networks which you know it's not
very popular anymore but it's you know
the first associative memories with with
neural nets and that that people can
revive the interest of some research
communities into neural nets in the
early eighties whereby mostly physicists
and condensed matter physicists and a
few psychologists it was it was job not
okay for engineers and computer
scientists to talk about neural nets and
they also showed me another paper that
had just been distributed as a preprint
whose title was optimal perceptual
inference and the
so the first paper on on Boltzmann
machines by Jeff Internet Jerry Sandusky
was talking about hidden units it was
talking about basically the part of
learning you know multi-layer neural
Nets with the other you know can are
more capable than just mere classifiers
so I said you know I need to meet these
people who because they already tried
see in the right problem and a couple
years later I was after I started my PhD
I participated in a workshop in a in
ladouche and that was organized by the
people I was working with and Terry was
one of the one of the speakers at that
workshop so I met him at that time it
was like early 80s now this is 1985
early 1985 so I met Terry Zaleski in
1985 in the workshop in France in a zoo
and a lot of people were there you know
from the server Lee neural net you know
Java field and a lot of people working
on so theoretical neuroscience and stuff
like that it was a fascinating workshop
I met also a couple couple people from
Bell Labs who eventually hired me a bell
as I came but this was several years
before I finished my PhD so I talked to
Terry Sandusky and I was telling him
about what I was working on which was
some version of back prop at the time
this was before back prop was a paper
and Terry was working on that talk at
the time this was you know before the
the you know the rumor heart intern
Williams paper on back prop has been
published but you know he was friends
with we Jeff you know this information
was circulating so he was already
working on trying to make this work for
net talk but he didn't he didn't tell me
and you went back to us and told Jeff
there is some kid in France who's
working on the same stuff we were
working on I see her and then a couple
most a few months later in June there
was another conference in France that
where Jeff was a keynote speaker and you
give a talk on Boston machine so of
course he was working on you know the
background paper and give this talk and
then there is you know 50 people around
even we want to talk to him and the
first thing you said to the organizer is
you know this guy yeah Nicole
it's because he had read my paper in the
Proceedings that was returned in French
yeah he could sort of read French and he
could see the math and he could figure
out what sort of background and so so
we're not together and that's why we
became friends I see well that's because
you basically you know independently
multiple groups independently we
invented or invented back prop pretty
much right or realize that the whole
idea of chain rule or what the optimal
control people call it at the a joint
statement which is you know really the
context in which back prop was really
invented this in context of optimal
control right in early 60s it's this
idea that you could use greater
understand basically with multiple kind
of stages is is what my prop really is
and that popped up in various contexts
at various times and but I think you
know the grammar part in turn Williams
paper is the one that popularized it and
then I'm you know fast forward a few
years you want up at AT&T Bell Labs
where you invented among many things the
net which we talked about in the inter
in the course and I remember when way
back that was a summer intern that ATG
thought that swell work of Michael
curtains and a few others and hearing
about your work even back then so so
tell me more about your your AT&T
Lynette
okay hearings so what happened is
actually started working on comes on
that when I was a postdoc a University
of Toronto with Jeff intestine I did the
first experiment where the code there
and did the first experiments there that
showed that if you had a very small data
set I was you know the data set I was
training on there was no end list or
anything like that back then so I you
know I drew a bunch of characters with
my mouse I had an immediate personal
computer which was a bit computer ever
and you know I drew a bunch of
characters and then use that you did
annotation to kind of you know increase
it and then use that as a way to test
performance and I compared things like
you fully connected net locally
connected that without shared weights
and then shared with networks it was
basically the first combat and and that
work really well for small relatively
small data sets could you could show
that you get better performance and no
overtraining with the completion of
architecture and when I go to Bell Labs
in
October 1988 the first thing I did was
first scale out the network because we
had faster computers a few months before
I go to Bell Labs my bus at the time
Larry Jekyll became my department head
at Bell Labs said oh we should order a
computer for you before you come what do
you want I say well you know here you
just roll over there is a Sun 4 which
was the latest greatest stuff it'd be
great if we if we had one and the other
one and I had one for myself you know it
was one for the HR department oh yeah
when just for me all right
and so what Larry told me he said yeah
you know why Bala's you don't get famous
by saving money so so that was like
awesome and and they had been working
already for for a while on character
recognition they had this enormous data
set called USPS that had 5,000 training
samples and so so immediately I you know
trained a designer commercial net which
was running at one basically and and
trained it on this data set and got
really good results by you know better
results than the other methods they had
been had been they had tried on it and
that other people had tried on this
dataset so that we knew we had something
fairly early on this is this was within
three months of me joining joining Bell
Labs and so that was the first version
of commercial net where we had a
completion with tried and we did not
have separate subsampling and pulling
layers so each each combination was
actually subsampling directly and the
reason for this is that we just could
not afford to have a coalition at every
location you know there was just too
much computation so the second version
had a separate completion and pooling
layer and sub standing I guess that's
the one that's called the net the net
one really we published a couple of
papers on this at indoor computation and
that nibs and so when interesting sorry
I gave a talk at nibs about but but this
work and Jeff Fenton was in the audience
and then I know I came back to my seat I
was sitting next to him and he said you
know there is one bit of information
you're in your talk which is that if you
do all the sensible things it actually
works and then show the after deadline
work went on to make history because
became widely adopted these ideas are
being widely adopted for reading checks
and yeah so the became ready adopted
within AT&T but not not very much
outside and you know I think it's a
little difficult for me to really
understand why but the several factors I
think so you know this was back in the
late 80s and there was no internet
you know we had email with FTP but there
was no internet really nobody you know
no two labs were using the same software
or hardware platform right you know some
people had Sun workstations all that
said you know other machines you know
using pcs whatever there was no such
thing as Python or MATLAB or anything
like that white people were writing
their own code I had written I had spent
a year and a half basically writing me
and Leon Powe too when it was two
students working together and we spent
are you gonna have basically just
writing a neural net simulator and at at
the time you know because there was no
MATLAB or Python you had to write your
own interpreter right to kind of control
it so we were torn Lisp interpreter and
so although Lynette was written in Lisp
using a numerical back-end very similar
to what we have now with you know blocks
that you can interconnect and I started
magic differentiation and all that stuff
that we familiar with now with you know
its fortune PI torsion tensorflow and
all those things
so so then we we developed a bunch of
applications we got together with a
group of engineers very smart people
some of them had you know were like
theoretical physicists who kind of have
turned engineer at Bell Labs
Chris Burgess was one of them who then
had a distinguished career at Microsoft
Research afterwards and Craig Knoll and
verge of a lucky ball and we were
collaborating with them to kind of make
the distinct notion practical and so
they developed together we developed
those your character education systems
and
that met integrating commercial Nets
with things like similar to things that
we now call CRFs for interpreting
sequences of characters not just to read
usually individual actors yeah right the
Lynette paper had passed the under
neural network and partially on the
autonomy to machinery right to put it
together yeah that's right that's so the
first the first half of the paper is on
is on commercial Nets and the paper is
most excited with for that and then the
second half very few people have read it
and it's about you know sort of sequence
level discriminative running and
basically structure prediction we you
know with that normalization so it's
very similar to where to CRF in fact it
would be CCRI for several years so that
was very successful except that today we
were celebrating the deployment of that
system in a major bank we worked with
this group that was mentioning that was
kind of doing the engineering of the
whole system and then another product
group in a different part of the country
that belong to a subsidiary of AT&T
called NCR so this is the company
register national cash registers right
they also build large medieval ATM
machines and they be a large check
reading machines for banks so there were
the customers if you want they were
using our check reading systems and they
deployed it in you know in the bank it
was a camera which bank it was the
deployed also the ATM machines in a
French bank so they could read the
cheque you would deposit and we were all
at a fancy restaurant celebrating the
deployment of this thing where when the
company announced that it was breaking
itself up so this was 1995 and AT&T
announced that he was breaking his cell
phone companies so you know there was
AT&T and then I was losing technologies
and NCR so NCR was spun off and recent
technologies was spun off and the
engineering group went with listen
technologies and the poor a group of
course with with NCR and the sudden the
sad thing is that the AT&T lawyers in
their infinite wisdom assigned the
patterns of there was a patent on
congressional Nets I see which is
thankfully expired they see expired in
2007 and years ago and this antipattern
to NCR but there was nobody in the NCR
who actually knew well even what
accomplished on it was really icy
and so the patent was in the hands of
people with no idea what they had and we
were in a different company that now
could not really develop the technology
and then our engineering team was in a
separate company because we went with
AT&T the engineering went with result
and the product worked with NCR so it
was a little depressing
so in addition to your early work you
know when your networks were were hot
you kept persisting on neuro networks
even when there was some sort of winter
for your knee so what was that like well
so I persisted and didn't persist in
some ways I was always convinced that
eventually those those techniques would
come back to the fore and sort of you
know people would figure out how to use
them in practice and it would be useful
so I always had that in the back of my
mind but but in 1996 when AT&T broke
itself up and all of our work on
character recognition basically was kind
of working out because the polygroups
was you know went in separate way i was
also promoted to department head and i
had to figure out what to work on and
this was the early days of the internet
we took in 1995 and I had the idea
somehow that one big problem about the
emergence of the internet was going to
be to bring all the knowledge that we
had on paper to the digital world and so
I started actually a project called
digital DJ vu which was to you know
compressed scanned documents and she
essentially so they could they could be
distributed over the Internet this
project was really fun for a while and
you know had some success although AT&T
really didn't know what to do with it
yeah I remember that
helping dissemination of online research
papers yeah that's right exactly and you
we scanned the entire proceedings of
nips and we made them available online
to kind of demonstrate how that worked
and you know we could compress like you
know high-resolution pages to transfer
kilobytes so confidence starting from
you know some of your much early work
has now
I'm pretty much taken over the field of
computer vision and starting to you know
encroach significantly even other fields
over this tell me about how you saw that
whole process so I tell you how I I
thought this was gonna happen early on
so first of all I always believed that
this was gonna work it required you know
fast computers and also data but I
always believed somehow that this was
gonna be the right thing to do
what I thought originally when I was at
Bell Labs that there was going to be
some sort of you know continuous
progress along these directions as
machines get got more powerful and you
know we're we've been designing chips to
run commercial nets at Bell Labs
Baraboo's are actually and and Hospital
graph separately had two different chips
for running coma Sean that's really
really efficiently and so you know we
thought there was gonna be kind of a
pickup of this and and kind of growing
interest and and sort of you know
continuous progress for it but in fact
because of the the sort of interest for
neural nets at the dying in the mid 90s
that didn't happen so it was kind of a
dark period of you know seven or six or
seven years between 1995 roughly and
2002 when basically nobody was working
on this in fact there were there was a
little bit of work there was some work
at at Microsoft in the early 2000s on
using commercial nets for Chinese
character recognition a decent resume at
school yeah exactly and and it was some
other small work for like face detection
and things like this in France and in
various other places it was very small I
discovered actually recently that
there's a couple groups that came up
with ideas that are essentially very
similar to commercial nets but never
quite published it you know the same way
for medical image analysis and those
were mostly in the context of commercial
systems and so it never kept quite made
it to the profession I mean it was after
the office to work on on commercial Nets
and they were not really aware of it but
but it sort of developed in parallel a
little bit so you know several people
got chemistry ideas
you know several years interval but then
it was really surprised by how fast
interest picked up after you know the
imagenet cycle 12 from 2012 so it's the
end of 2012 it was kind of a very
interesting event at ECC V in Florence
where there was a workshop on imagenet
and everybody knew that you know
Jacqueline's team Alex crew jetski and
SOC ever had had won by a large margin
and so everybody was waiting for an
extra desk is talk and most people in
the configuration committee had no idea
what cumshaw net was I mean they heard
me talk about it actually had a Nevada
talk at cvpr in 2000 when I talked about
it but but most people you know it not
paid much attention to it senior people
did you know they knew what it was but
the more junior people in the community
were really had no idea what it was and
so an extra Jeske just you give this
talk and it doesn't explain what the
conversion that is because the assumes
everybody knows because he comes from
machine learning so he says you know
here is a we everything is connected and
the you know how we transform the data
and results we get can assuming that
everybody knows what it is a lot of
people are incredibly surprised and and
you could see the opinion of people
changing as he was kind of giving his
talk now you know very senior people in
the field so they think that that that
workshop was the defining moment that
swayed a lot of computer vision
community yeah definitely that's that's
where it happened right there so today
you retain a faculty position at weiu
and you also read their facebooking I
research um I know you have a pretty
unique point of view on how corporate
research should be done do I share your
thoughts on that yeah so I mean one of
the beautiful things that you know that
I managed to do at Facebook in the last
four years is that I was I was given a
lot of freedom to set up fair the way I
thought was the most appropriate because
this was the first research organization
within Facebook you know Facebook is a
certain engineering centric company and
so far was refocused on sort of survival
or short-term things and
book was you know about to turn 10 years
old had you know had a successful IPO
and was basically thinking about the
next 10 years right tell me Mark
Zuckerberg was thinking you know what is
going to be important for the next 10
years and and the survival of the
company was not in question anymore so
this is the kind of transition where a
large company can can start to think or
it was not such a large company at the
time Facebook at 5,000 employees or so
but but it had the luxury to think about
the next 10 years and what would be
important in in technology and and and
Mark decided that Mark and his team
decided that a IO is going to be a
crucial piece of technology for for
connecting people which is the mission
of Facebook and so they explored several
ways to can I build an effort in the eye
that had a small internal group and
Jamie group experimenting with
commercial nets and stuff that were
getting really good results in face
recognition and various other things
which piques their interest and they
explored the idea of you know hiring a
bunch of young researchers or acquiring
a company or things like this and they
settled on the idea of you know hiring
someone senior in the field and then
kind of setting setting up a research
organization and and it was a bit of a
culture shock initially because the way
research operates in the company is very
different from from engineering why do
you have longer timescales and horizon
and researchers tend to be very
conservative about the choice of places
where they want to work and and I made
very clear very early on that research
needs to be open that researchers need
to not only be encouraged to publish but
we even mandated to publish and also be
evaluated on criteria that are similar
to what we used to evaluate I can you
know actually make you know researchers
and so you know what Mark and and Mike
Schafer the city of the company who is
my boss now said you know they said
Facebook is a very open company we
distribute a lot of stuff in open source
you know
you know shred the CTO comes from the
open source world he was he was illa
before that and a lot of people came
from that world so that was in the DNA
of the company so that maybe we're
confident that we could kind of set up
open research organization and then the
fact that the the company is not
obsessive-compulsive about IP as some
other companies are it makes it much
easier to collaborate with universities
and have arrangements by which a person
can have a foot in industry and a foot
in academia and as you find that
valuable yourself oh absolutely
yeah so if you look at the my
publications or the last four years the
vast majority of them are publications
when my students at NYU because at
Facebook I you know I I did a lot of you
know organizing their lab hiring you
know centric direction and advising and
things like this but I don't get
involved in individual research projects
to get my name on papers and you know I
don't care to get my papers anymore but
but it's a setting out someone else's
your great work exacting alright great
verges and you never want to put
yourself you know you want to kind of
stay behind the scene and you want you
don't want to put your site in
competition with people you know in your
lab in that case I'm sure you get asked
this a lot but hope can answer for all
the people watching this video as well
what advice do you have for someone
wanting to get involved in the I have
pretty frickin - yeah I mean it's such a
different world now than it was when I
when I got started but I think what's
great now is it's very easy for people
to get involved at some level right I
mean the tools that are available is so
easy to use now you know with tons of
hope I torch whatever you can you know
you can have a relatively cheap computer
and you're you know in your bedroom and
and basically train you or your your
commercial net or recurrent net to do to
do whatever and there's a lot of tools
you can learn a lot from from online
material but this without it was not a
very onerous so you see high school
students now playing with this right
which is kind of which is great I think
and they're certainly you're growing in
yes from the student population to learn
about machine learning and AI and it's
very exciting for for young people that
I find that wonderful I think so my
advice is if you want to get into this
make yourself useful so make a
contribution to an open-source project
for example or make or make an
implementation of some standard
algorithm that you couldn't find the
code of online but you would like to you
know make it available to other people
so take a paper that you think is
important and then you know we promote
the algorithm and then put it up and
open-source package or contribute to one
of those epistles packages and if the
stuff you write is interesting useful
you will you will get noticed
you know maybe you'll get a nice job at
a company you really want a job at or
maybe you'll get accepted and your
favorite ph.d program or or things like
this I think that's a good way to get
started so open source contributions is
a good way to enter the community yeah
that's right leerin yeah that's right
thanks a lot y'all don't start skating
oh no need for many years is though
fascinating to hear all these details of
all the stories have gone on over the
years
oh yeah there's many many stories like
this that you know reflecting back at
the moment when they when they happen
you don't realize you know what what
importance they might take ten or twenty
years later
yeah thank you Thanks